hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Hobbit review hopefully you guys
have had a chance to see it just in case
you haven't I'm gonna start with my
non-spoilery part first and then I'll
get into specific moments I'm a huge
Peter Jackson fan and even though it's
been a long long time since I've read
any talking I'm a huge fan of the books
and the films I still think the animated
Hobbit movie probably one of the
scariest cartoons I ever watched the
child that's actually a much more
faithful adaptation to the original
novel so if you want a Hobbit movie
that's just the book it doesn't have a
bunch of extra stuff in it just watch
that original cartoon the actual Hobbit
novel is very short and though a lot of
people forget it was specifically
intended for children it was written for
young children being that this movie was
part 3 I went in thinking a little bit
about that I totally didn't mind that
they took this short book and turned it
into a 7 plus hour movie but I feel like
when they release it on DVD that's how
they need to market it as like one
really long movie it's just that for
this movie there's no way you're gonna
understand the what or the why of the
action without having seen the first two
parts I saw both of those so no problems
there but I considered a big thumbs down
that the movie cannot stand by itself
for example look at the Lord of the
Rings trilogy Return of the King was a
much stronger narrative you could watch
it all by itself and it would still feel
like it had a beginning middle and an
end
although the joke is there that they had
like five different endings to that
movie it's just that the Hobbit part
three feels like it was taken out of
Peter Jackson's extended cut for the
second film desolation of Smaug like
this would have worked a lot better if
part two had been a four-hour movie and
they just used this as the third act
find the mountain defeat the dragon
battle the other armies and take a
Hobbit nap for about a hundred years
till Gandalf comes back for Frodo in
another adventure all those issues
inside this was classic Peter Jackson
middle-earth which I totally love martin
freeman and richard armitage were
amazing they were the real stars of the
film Ian McKellen as Gandalf had a big
role as did Lee pace Evangeline Lilly in
Orlando Bloom and if you didn't
recognize him the new Bennett actually
played azog the Defiler he just did all
that mocap so you don't recognize them
just like Benedict Cumberbatch did Smaug
so anytime you see as I'm the Defiler
just think of him as being Deathstroke
all them did an amazing job all the
actors but the friendship between Bilbo
and Thorin is the core of this
film and that did breakthrough what
ended up being mostly a to our extended
action scene like if you remember the
battle for Gondor and Return of the King
imagine that is the whole movie just
that battle normally that would be
another giant thumbs-down but because
i'm trying to think of this is like a
seven or eight hour movie it works fine
in that context there's just not a whole
lot of story in part three
what story there is is mostly in service
to setting up the events of Lord of the
Rings the first movie fellowship there
is like this seamless transition between
this movie and fellowship that
everyone's gonna really enjoy so if you
ever find yourself with like 20 hours to
kill you could totally do the Star Wars
prequels original trilogy treatment
where you watch all six films in
chronological order just make sure you
do it with the extended editions because
that's how it's done you just got to do
the extended editions overall I gave you
the film a solid b-plus for the sheer
weight of accomplishment in the fact
that it works so well on this extended
idea of like this seven plus eight hour
movie I would have given it an A but I
did have two thumbs down for the lack of
story it just did not have enough to
exist without those other two films one
thing to note though is all the bonus
content that goes into building this
world Peter Jackson is one of the best
people when it comes to bonus features
so I'm definitely gonna be buying the
extended edition blu-rays hopefully they
don't wait too long to release those so
now I'm gonna get into my favorite
moments and do a much more detailed
analysis like in my top 5 so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet so starting with top five moments
number five bard kills Smaug this
definitely should have been the end of
the second movie but it was such a huge
deal and it tees up an almost Return of
the King type moment where bard takes
leadership of Dale in the Canon he
actually did become the first king of
what you would call new Dale and the
events following the movie so they
really are trying to mirror a lot of the
beats in the original trilogy
Benedict Cumberbatch was barely in the
movie though which was kind of a bummer
I was watching the in 3d so the action
was a little out of focus and there were
some brightness issues with the screen I
was watching it on but that had nothing
to do with the film itself like that was
just the venue I was at I would caution
people singing in 3d I would recommend
just seeing a normal print of it IMAX
would be awesome to just try to avoid 3d
the only thing about this that slowed it
down was the child like his son I
understand why they included him in the
film
they could have cut him out but this is
a story written for children so they
want to make
the film for children too so they have
to have a child do this big action
sequence it's just whenever he's on
screen it just really slows things down
number four Thranduil versus everyone
Lee pace was so awesome at being a dick
in this movie he's like the ultimate emo
elf
if Martin Freeman flipping people off
behind the scenes in his Bilbo makeup
isn't enough to crash tumblr Lee pace
and Thranduil makeup will finish the job
seriously I have seen more Tumblr posts
on Thranduil than anything else ever
it's like you have the lead paced fandom
crashing into the Lord of the Rings
fandom and it's just going crazy in
terms of dramatic art there's not a
whole lot for his character in this
movie other than to tie up a minor story
that they teased in the prologue of the
first film get back the gems of pure
starlight this actually though is one of
the most interesting things in the movie
that they don't mention like one of the
biggest Easter eggs I saw so the
conflict that Lee pace is seeking
payment for is based on this ancient
conflict this ancient feud between the
dwarves and the elves that goes all the
way back to King Fingal he was actually
the first Andorian King that's the group
of elves that Thranduil belongs to
single was like the high king of the
elves of the cinder elves there's a lot
of different groups of elves most of
them had their own cultures they're
mostly Dylan aided by the big three
groups but it gets way more complicated
than that the reason that the dwarves
were feuding with the elves was over a
matter of payment for this really famous
necklace called nag Lumiere it was made
of those white gems of pure starlight
the dwarves constructed it and then
later think'll high king of the elves
had one of the simmer ills added to it
it ended up becoming like the finest
example of dwarven craftsmanship in that
age I think it was the second age when
it was crafted maybe the end of the
first stage I know everyone's asking
about a similar Orion TV series I'll
address that at the end of this video so
the doors felt like they didn't get fare
payment for that fine craftsmanship
thus the feud began they went back and
forth and then finally Thranduil ended
it when Thorin was dead when Thorin died
he left the mountain with his payment
that's like the super short version of
it number three Bilbo and Thorin they
are like the emotional core of this film
I would argue the most important part if
not for them there would have been no
movie
Martin Freeman and Richard Armitage were
just amazing Thorin going crazy was a
lot of fun to watch I kept wondering how
far they'd push it like how far
over-the-top they'd make his host
Nations I will say that the gold sucking
him under was pretty trippy I did laugh
a little it did get a little silly but
so much fun watching their back and
forth especially before Bilbo decided to
tell him about the Arkenstone
the connection between them didn't quite
reach the level of Sam wise and Frodo
but they are like the Sam wise and Frodo
of this movie number two clad real
defeats Sauron this was almost a tie
with my number one moment back when the
second film had already come out and
Peter Jackson had started talking about
part three
he said that we get to see Galadriel
lose her imagine that being said
with Peter Jackson's voice it just
sounds so funny coming out of his lips
the CG action was just a little too
crazy a little too incoherent just them
fighting the nine it was just a little
too weird so out of that whole sequence
of events I just zero in on khalad drill
and Sauron it does give you good sense
of the scope of her powers and just to
give you something to compare to the
elven rings of power the three that were
given to them by Sauron Elrond is the
keeper of the most powerful one he's
still not as powerful as Galadriel she
also has one and gandalf has the other
which i think is kind of funny Thranduil
last king of the elves does not have one
of the elven rings of power they don't
make a big deal about it in the movie
but the Rings do have power they do
enhance their abilities but they all
have different properties and collateral
is still the most powerful person on
middle-earth next to Sauron for those
that are wondering about the Rings after
the fact there were twenty rings created
in total but when the One Ring was
destroyed in the fires of Mount Doom all
the power faded from the other rings and
my number one moment
the transition from young Bilbo to Lord
of the Rings Bilbo this was not like the
most eye gouging intense moment but the
way Peter Jackson cut the film just
makes it fit so perfectly on your
bookshelf and fit into this context of
marathon viewing I feel like the idea of
the marathon watch is such a big deal
today that the way people edit films now
these big trilogies is gonna fit into
that much more it's like this one
continuous narrative with no significant
act breaks you could watch all six films
and they'd be seamless it just it works
really well for these kinds of epic
fantasy series that you're meant to
reread and rewatch several times which I
will totally begin doing now let me know
that what was your favorite moment from
the movie and here's my big question for
you guys would you like to see them try
to adapt the similar alien as a TV
series it would probably follow the
events of the war
the jewels in and around that so it'd be
about 2400 years before the events of
this movie interesting sidenote in
middle-earth history it was after that
war the war for the simmer else that
Thran duels father came to the West to
establish the kingdom of the cinder
that's how long ago that was Game of
Thrones kind of touches on that type of
epic scope but most of the stuff that
we've seen from the series is all in
present-day george RR martin has written
the context for ancient history but he
hasn't exported quite as much as tokine
explored the ancient history of
middle-earth so on all great experience
just if you're gonna watch it and you
haven't if you watched the spoiler part
of this video try to avoid 3d I would
not recommend the 3d tomorrow for those
who are asking I am working on an arrow
bonus video and I've got some special
Legend of Korra stuff coming for The
Legend of Korra fans the finale the
two-part finale is gonna air Thursday at
midnight so be sure to stay up late on
Thursday and subscribe to get all that
stuff right now if you're on your mobile
phone or on your tablet there's new
links that you can click on up here new
mobile links I think it's right over
here in this corner but it's the same as
the links over here click here for the
last game of Thrones viral trailer for
season 5 new season 5 footage yay and
click here to catch up on Legend of
Korra before Thursday remember it's
gonna be like the last Legend of Korra
on TV ever don't be sad though so let's
all high five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you